[Musique]
toutes ces transformations physiques que
vous aimez ferrer sur vous et manière de
vous cacher en nombre de tours au
toujours jos une façon jouer la comédie
mais façon élémentaire en fait au départ
photos raw telle envie de jouer
détracteurs c'est souvent quand on est
gosse est souvent à sa conférence
on pense souvent à des transformations
françoise déguisé en les choses
psychologique ça vient plus tard
j'en parlais de ce matin puisque c'est
le sujet de ce film enfin du plaisir que
vous avez à vous déguiser à vous
transformer mais est ce qu'on peut dire
que toutes ces transformations il ya
quand même un dénominateur commun
oui bah le dénominateur commun c'est le
plaisir de la comédie quoi moi c'est le
plaisir d'entrer j'aime pas l'expression
entrer dans la peau de personnages parce
que c'est faux mais plaisir de
représenter des personnages de faire des
portraits de gens que l'on peut croiser
dans la rue en grossissant le trait bien
sûr pour rendre la chose comique que
nick mais en même temps toujours un peu
un peu pitoyable
oui parce que je crois que tout est
mélangé maintenant c'est plus de notre
temps de faire une chose entièrement
comique ou entièrement dramatique
je crois que
la vie il a ainsi fait une version 1.1
entièrement ben c'est une chose triste a
priori et puis les pins interdite qui
s'y passe des choses drôles du tout est
vraiment mélanger je crois pas qu'on
puisse devenir le représentant
représentatif d'un genre complètement
pur pour le site internet que comique ou
dramatique ça ça m'intéresse je vous
posais la question piège avec voudrait
qu'elle est pour nous la chose la plus
importante de la vie ça vous rappelle
quelque chose
ça me rappelle un film lequel moi j'ai
déjà répondu à cette question oui au
cinéma réussite et une interview oui
dans robert et robert voilà avec macha
mairie avec macha méril et puis et celle
mort quand je me souviens de cette
séquence alors maintenant répondu je me
souviens plus que je répondais c'était
quoi je vous disais il ya beaucoup de
choses importantes enfin je pense que
vous et lui dit un peu la question oui
c'est ce que je pense c'est que oui ça
serait trop difficile d'y répondre
ce serait trop long à répondre à tout ça
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
important ces choses comme ça quel que
soit ce thème star avait une idée assez
précise la carrière que vous voulez
faire j'ai une idée assez précise et
puis disons qu'il ya tout ça est en
gestation
bien sûr que j'attends parce qu'on est
on est on est soumis à un minimum de
choses comme ça et puis de 10 dès que
peuvent avoir les gens sur vous mais
disons que j'ai quand même une idée
précise j'aimerais bien mois plus tard
réaliser des films et je crois que tous
les travaux qui consistent à jouer soit
sur scène soit au cinéma comme acteur
font partie d'un tout qui j'espère me
mènera un jour à pouvoir réaliser des
films quoi mais j'ai pas de
de précipitations à dessus
[Musique]